(film reel clicks)
- I'm in Cyprus and I have to drive
on the left side of the road right now.
(man laughs)
- Hold on (indistinct)
(intense electronic music)
- Two people-
- Wait,
why are you guys leaving?
- [Man] Two people left the car.
- McDonald's ice cream
machine is always broken.
- Welcome to the vlog
dude, I'm vlogging today.
- What are you posting this on?
- It's called the youtube.com.
- Oh!
- So it's like this,
like platform for like
video cloud-based sharing
of high quality video content.
They even do HD.
- (indistinct) How
would you share a cloud?
- So it's- well, it's like an HD thing.
- So it's like, TV or something?
- So McDonald's is being
investigated by the FTC,
And I'm here in Cyprus
making a documentary series
for the first time in a while.
(mid tempo lofi music begins)
And I want to show you some of it
and I just need to give
you a bit of an update
on McDonald's and all the
things happening right now.
(upbeat electronic music)
(car hits item in road)
Oh (beep)
- [Radio Announcer] Cyprus remains a,
or that could have set off a
full scale war.. (indistinct)
(upbeat electronic music)
- I'm making like an announcement video,
- A little video for your YouTube channel
- Yeah, my little YouTube channel.
- I'm also vlogging.
- Are you?
- What's going on?
You're also vlogging things.
- Yes!
(upbeat music)
(indistinct)
- That's cool. Just
bring your cat with us.
- These donkeys don't belong to anyone.
I'm going to jump off a cliff.
I got to vlog it for my video.
So today's video is not
going to be an explainer.
I know you come to this
channel to learn things.
You'll learn a little
bit about the lawsuit
and the FTC investigation,
but today I want to
give you just an update
and tell you a little bit more
about the series I'm doing
before we get into that.
I want to thank today's
sponsor who is Better Help.
I've said this before.
I'm a big believer in therapy.
I believe that therapy needs
to be normalized and it needs
to be way more accessible and
way more common for people.
I started doing therapy
with a licensed professional
therapist almost two years ago,
and it has changed my life.
It is not a crisis line.
It is a place where you can
go to find a good therapist.
Finding a good therapist is kind of hard,
especially when you only have
the options in your city.
Better Help is an online
thing. It's remote.
You can browse thousands of
therapists and choose one.
And then if you don't really
fit with the therapist,
which is a very common thing,
you can easily switch
to another one for free,
no, like calling your insurance
and figuring out who's in network.
And that whole debacle
that is just sort of,
when you are already looking for therapy,
you don't want to be like stressing out
about finding a therapist.
It's super easy to sign
up, within 48 hours
you could be talking to a professional.
I really believe in therapy
and believe that better
help is doing a good job,
trying to make there be more accessible.
So there's link in my description
betterhelp.com/JohnnyHarris.
When click that link, it
helps support this channel,
but it also gives you
10% off your first month,
a better help.
You can try it out and see if
it works for you. Thank you.
Better help for supporting
this channel and for supporting
the journalism I'm doing here in Cyprus.
Now let's get to the update
(high intensity techno music) (indistinct)
- First off.
McDonald's, holy smokes.
So I made this video about
the ice cream machines.
Can I get an ice cream cone?
- Ice cream machine is broken,
ice cream machine is broken.
And it sounds like there's
a story behind that one.
Doesn't it?
- This was like back in the spring.
And I didn't think this
video was going to give us a
30 minute video about ice cream machines
and suddenly there's like 8 million views
or something like people clearly
wanted to learn about this.
It made a pretty big splash.
And then it turns out according
to the wall street journal
who just reported on this,
the FTC is now investigating this issue,
the ice cream machine makers
to see if there's something
weird going on. I think there's
something weird going on.
At least that's what
the evidence points to.
I don't know what weirdness is going on,
but something weird is going on
and it's not just a
four-hour cleaning cycle.
So I'm going to keep my eye on this.
The wall street journal
seems to be like really into
reporting on these ice cream
machine makers, like me
and the wall street journal.
They're like in lockstep right now.
(laughs)
And,
and so I'm going to keep my
eye on this reporting and see
what happens next.
Meanwhile, if you remember from
the ice cream machine story,
there is that startup called Kytch.
That is the one that sort of
got blackballed by McDonald's.
When they tried to invent a fix
for the ice cream machine makers,
they have filed the lawsuit
and they even got awarded
a restraining order
because they have alleged
and have very good evidence
for the fact that McDonald's
and Taylor and this whole cadre
of ice cream machine people,
have gotten a hold of their technology
and are using it to basically make
the same thing for themselves,
which is a big no-no.
You don't do that.
So this is still a developing thing,
but the fact is that, like,
I think I stepped into a can
of worms that I didn't know was
going to be a big deal.
And I think the video that I
made may have had some effect
on all of this, which is
sort of a weird thing.
Wired also put out a really
solid article on this,
that I'll link in the description
Overall, it feels good
to be doing YouTube,
but also feel like I'm
doing real journalism
and that it's been
validated on a bigger scale.
Cool.
You know, I left Vox
and felt a little bit
insecure about the fact
that like I'm leaving a
journalistic institution.
Like, what does that mean for me
in my reputation as a
storyteller and a journalist,
and part of me likes this freedom
and this ability to be more creative
and more personal and like be able to talk
to you like I'm doing right now.
But part of me also feels a sense of like,
I still want to be like
in the journalism world,
which I guess gets to
a second little update,
which is a video that I
made with the New York times
last year, got nominated for an Emmy,
which is like, okay, that's cool.
The Emmy's are sort of
like an old legacy thing,
like for like legacy TV,
but more and more they're
they're updated and,
and recognizing work that is being done
now on this platform.
And that's kind of exciting.
I'm actually working on another piece
with the New York times right now
that we'll publish in the fall.
So keep an eye out for that.
Man. So many updates.
(cheerful music)
- Okay.
Cyprus, let me tell you about
what I'm doing here in Cyprus,
Man, this is,
this is probably the most
exciting thing I have to say,
where to start.
On my way over to Cyprus,
me, Izzy,
and the boys stopped by Sicily
and have a sort of before
back to school vacation altogether,
first time I was able to
practice my Italian though,
boil boys, the Italian
incessantly, is not Italian,
it's literally a different language,
but even the Italian they speak
is like, man, that was hard.
It was really hard, but
boy is the food good.
(fill reel clicks)
Sicily is a very wild place.
And, and while there,
there was some very
stressful stuff that came up.
There was like a bunch of EU announcements
about the borders being closed.
And we were up late talking to VCs
and founders about bright trip,
which is a huge thing in my life right now
that I'm just not going to go into,
but like bright trip is growing
and we're trying to
raise a bunch of money.
And like,
it's actually really hard to
do entrepreneurial things.
I've decided like it's actually
like not easy to do it,
which is why like most people don't do it.
And I see now why people
just sort of flake out
on it after a while,
because it's really hard and emotional
to try to build a startup,
but it's happening.
It's working,
we're building bride trip
and it's turning into a pretty cool thing.
But anyway,
it was a wonderful time with
the kids out on the road,
again, after many years
of not being on the road.
And then is he in the boys,
flew back to Washington
DC and I flew here.
(high energy music)
So this is probably why most
of you clicked on this video.
Maybe you care about ice
cream machine makers.
Maybe you care about my Emmy nomination,
but I'm pretty sure most
of you care about like the
documentary explainer work that I do.
And the good news is that
I'm doing it. I'm back.
I'm back on the road. I'm doing it.
- I'm back, baby.
- The past year. My life
has been very strange.
Vox borders was canceled last year.
Sort of around this time
and that's when I really decided that
I needed to build this channel.
So I started making a bunch of videos,
tons and tons and tons of
videos that you've been seen.
I've been in the office making videos,
but I need to tell you that
my heart, my heart is here.
It's out here. It's me on
the road, talking to people,
looking at complicated stuff,
trying to understand it,
pouring over maps and documents
and looking at archive like
that is where my heart is.
And I haven't been able to do that since,
since borders was canceled,
mainly because this
channel wasn't big enough
to financially support that and COVID-19,
but both of those things have changed.
This channel has grown significantly.
Thanks to all of you being here
and COVID-19 is kind of going away.
- Bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
Hey, you live here in Pittsburgh.
- No, it's not.
Let's be honest. It's not going away.
Like we thought it was,
I thought it was so
there was this one day,
Izzy and I were driving in Iceland.
The boys were asleep and we were thinking,
it was like two in the morning.
It was like light outside.
Beautiful.
And we were talking as Izzy
was talking about like, well,
what do you miss about,
about, you know, Vox?
And I said, well, I miss my colleagues.
I've missed like hanging
out with people that I,
that inspire me.
And then I said, I miss
being out on the road.
And she's like, dude, go
like go out on the road.
Like, like you can do
that now on your channel.
And it just hit me. And I was like,
I knew at some point I was going to do it,
but like now's the time.
So then the question was,
what story do I tell? What place do I go?
And Cyprus has been on my mind since 2014.
I studied peace and conflict resolution
in my master's degree.
And I took an entire course
about conflict resolution
and mediation and Cyprus.
The conflict here in Cyprus
was the subject of that course.
In fact, that course,
in addition to my experience in Tijuana
and so many other experiences like that
are what woke me up to my obsession
and interest in divisions
and lines and maps.
So we spent a couple of months
just diving deep into Cyprus.
And then we came here.
I came here with Jack,
my assistant producer,
and this guy, Corey pop.
I've never traveled with a
real camera person before.
So to have Corey pop, who is
a DP that worked on explained
and is just incredibly
good at what he does
to have him with me to help tell this
story was a really special moment.
So for the past 10 days,
we've been on the road,
traversing this entire island,
talking to military,
going on military vessels,
going into buffer zones,
talking to the UN.
It has been a deep dive
in reporting on Cyprus.
And I am so excited to share
these stories with you.
And while I was here, I
met up with these guys.
I invited Thomas and Nathaniel
to come with me to Cyprus
because mainly,
because I just wanted to
hang out with my friends.
Like these are friends of mine that
I've made on the internet that
I talk to often, but like,
don't get to hang out with very often.
It's like an overall, it was
just a good time to reflect
and to bond and to have
some like social interaction
for the first time in a really long time.
- Give this guy a spritz?
- No.
(laughs)
(indistinct)
- And now they're gone and I am still here
reporting in Cyprus.
The stories that you're
going to see me tell
in this new series, which is
called by the way, uncharted,
that's the name of the series.
The stories you're going to see me tell
are going to feel like me.
They're going to feel like videos
I've always made,
After all, I can't change that.
It's sort of comes from my curiosity,
that comes from my voice,
but they're going to feel different.
They're going to feel more intentional.
They're going to feel more visually rich.
They're going to feel more human.
I hope, talk to a lot more
people than I've ever talked to.
I was able to focus on the
interviews because I had a camera
person, you know, Corey
was there shooting.
And so I wasn't there
fiddling with audio and, and,
and getting the frame, right.
It was actually like just
focused on the conversations
and hopefully there'll
be just better reported,
more sensitive, more clear,
more informative than
anything I've ever done.
I've grown up as a storyteller
and over the past year and a half.
And I'm really excited to
share this story with you.
A story that has been on my mind since,
since I sat in that
classroom in grad school.
And I was like, someday,
I will tell this story.
And I've been working
with my composer, Tom Fox,
who has created an entire
custom score for Cyprus.
It's like synth and
orchestral and minimal,
but also like very intense and emotional.
You're listening to a
little bit of it right now.
(intense music)
So I probably shouldn't be
giving away all the juicy stuff
of this series, but I just can't help it.
There's too much good stuff.
So let me just give you
a little nugget of what
I've been seeing over the past 10 days..
Or the past several decades.
This has just been no man's land.
(intense music)
There was commerce, there was an economy,
there was trade.
This place was thriving,
and then it just collapsed
(intense music)
So that's it. That's my update, everyone.
It feels really good
to be back on the road.
I am exhausted.
My brain is still in this like
middle ground where I'm still
trying to like, make the
stories like come together.
There's still so much reconciling
I have to do in the
script, but I feel good.
I feel good to be here
back in my natural habitat
on the road, telling
stories, talking to people,
traversing a new place and
trying to understand it and
trying to translate it
to a bigger audience,
so that you can catch a glimpse
of what's happening here
and the emotions and the people
and the politics at stake.
That is my goal.
That is the update. Thank
you all for being here.
And I will see you very soon
as I kick off uncharted.
(intense music)